[Musique]
toujours en relation avec la période des
vacances une période où on a tendance à
consommer plus et donc à jeter plus
sachez aussi que nous produisons à peu
près 13 millions de tonnes d'ordures par
an dont une énorme quantité de matières
premières ni exploité dû faire par
exemple de l'ue minium du cuivre est
évidemment du plastique comme si tout
cela ne suffisait pas on a même inventé
des objets à jeter au départ les objets
à jeter ont été faits pour nous
simplifier la vie
laver des couches de bébé par exemple
n'a jamais été une partie de plaisir
mais les fabricants ne se sont pas
arrêtés là l'objet à jeter après une
place grandissante dans notre vie
quotidienne sans que nous ayons
l'impression de gaspiller dans la
plupart des cas l'évolution des objets
s'est faite en plusieurs temps pour le
rasoir par exemple au départ c'était un
objet d'une seule pièce qu'il suffisait
déguisée de temps en temps puis on a
inventé les lames rechargeables le
rasoir reste mais les lames se jettent
dernière étape c'est le rasoir entier
qui se jette
c'est la même évolution qu'on subit
beaucoup d'objets au détriment de la
qualité du produit
nous n'avons gagné que les quelques
secondes nécessaires au remplissage d'un
stylo ou à la recharge d'un briquet tout
se gère actuellement des nappes aux
assiettes en passant par les brosses à
dents les mouchoirs
les lampes de poche les briquets
sans compter les stylos et les
vaporisateurs en tout genre de même que
les sacs poubelles
et puis le dernier né de la série
l'appareil photo a ajouté que l'on
trouvera bientôt dans les grandes
surfaces après avoir pris les photos
qu'il contient vous n'en verrez au
laboratoire il faudra casser l'appareil
pour retirer la pellicule
tous ces objets coûte cher cet appareil
par exemple sera vendu entre 25 et 30
francs
c'est à dire environ le quart du prix
d'un appareil de poche normal
réutilisables indéfiniment ou presque
et au train où vont les choses pourquoi
ne pas imaginer qu'un jour nous
jetterons notre voiture
dès que le réservoir sera vide
[Musique]